pour
[Musique]
retrouvez cette semaine à l'espace
philippe noiret le film astérix et le
secret de la potion magique com vous
propose en sortie nationale
alexandre astier donc signe ce film avec
une histoire originale
on retrouve donc les ingrédients de base
de ces personnages prennent vie et
notamment donc c'est d'irréductibles
gaulois et je le césar etc et il va
ajouter comme ingrédient donc des
personnages notamment un personnage
devenu méchant
voilà très bien très bien dessiné et là
il a reçu en salle et le son le
culinaire de d'alfred hitchcock puisque
meilleure élimination améliorer le
feeling et il va aussi ajouté un autre
ingrédient alors ça je vous dévoilerai
pas mes un autre personnage moderne qui
va trancher un petit peu dans l'univers
moustachu de
de la bd voilà donc c'est à retrouver
cette semaine donc la potion magique
d'alexandre astier avec l'humour qu'on
lui connaît
cette semaine à l'espace philippe noiret
[Musique]